realized that you went to school for
journalism I guess okay right so from
that time when you were sort of on the
couch watching those episodes what was
the timeframe when you actually stepped
foot in that what writers room and right
it was actually nine years and and I and
there was a progression along the way I
got out of college I worked for about
six or eight months in San Francisco
then moved back to Los Angeles and
that's when I started writing spec
scripts and I wrote a spec movie by
myself then I had a partner and she and
I wrote spec sitcoms and this was
simultaneous to doing commercial
production I eventually got a chance to
work on in a production capacity on
movies and TV and would write more spec
scripts when I was unemployed and then
got into the directors guild as a second
assistant director and that's when I got
my first almost break there where the
producers brother of the movie I was
working on what was trying to help
develop their television part of their
production company and his assistant
learned that I would had spec scripts
and asked to read the spec script My
partner and I had written and said hey
this is really good and got it to an
agent an incredibly prestigious Asian
who was William Goldman's agent at the
time and Joan Didion the agency I know
it was the agent and in in hindsight I
know that the agency was just doing this
powerful producer's brother
a favor and they took us on as clients
on a 30 day trial basis and of course
they said this tripped out two shows
that said you know we got writers
already this is okay so that came and
went I kept writing I kept working as an
assistant director and I and I got
encouragement along the way I was the
second assistant director on a movie
called national lampoon's vacation the
first one where they go to fake
Disneyland place their Walley world and
Chevy Chase was the star of the movie
and heard learn somehow that I had
written spec scripts and was incredibly
generous and said give me one I want to
read it so I had written a script for a
show called police squad which was the
TV predecessor to the Naked Gun movies
and Chevy read it I still have the
script in my off
now he gave me a B+ which was pretty
nice of him and then wrote notes on it
and then signed it Mel Brooks but but at
the end of it and he said this to me
personally too he said seriously you
have talent and you should keep doing
this and I can't tell you what that
meant to me at that time to have
somebody who's a big comedy star and had
been a writer himself on variety shows
including Saturday Night Live and The
Smothers Brothers and so on say yes keep
doing this so I had that encouragement
also my other break was that I aside for
life break I met my wife and her uncle
was a CBS current comedy executive and
he read my spec scripts and said these
are good and he got them to an agent who
eventually became my agent but he read
the police squad script and the script I
had written with my former partner said
these are excellent I cannot represent
you because you're not writing with your
partner and police squad is not on TV
and there's nothing on TV like it so
write another script I wrote a cheer
script called him up he read the script
I didn't hear from him for several weeks
and so I had to make that dreaded phone
call where you're you haven't heard so
you're sure it's not going to be good
news and he took the phone call and I
when I asked if he'd read the script he
said yeah it was really funny and then
just stopped talking and I said isn't
that good for a comedy that it's funny
he said yes but it's too dirty even for
cheers it's like an r-rated cheers which
became a joke between us as years went
on and he represented me because I did
nothing but squeaky clean family
comedies like The Cosby Show and the
TGIF shows on ABC's family lineup and no
one thought I could write adult comedy
and I almost begged him to take this 20
year old script out at one point in time
and send it around but it took time for
me to get that good and so when he said
you have to write another script beyond
the cheers I wrote another cheers and
then he made some suggestions and I took
the notes and rewrote the script a
little bit and at that point he said
okay I can represent you and I don't
continue with this story because then he
called me two months later I had a job
as an assistant director then I was the
first ad by that time on a show called
NOx landing one of the nighttime soap
operas so the bills were getting paid
and they calls me up in early September
late August of 1984 and says I have
great news there Bill Cosby is doing a
new situation comedy and they read your
script and they really like it and they
want to hire you but you've got to go to
New York for the job well the previous
year for I idolized Bill Cosby listened
to his records as a child so this was an
unbelievable offer previous year though
when my wife was pregnant and we had an
eight-year-old I was out of town doing
the only job I could find for four
months so it was would have been
disastrous for my marriage to leave town
again so I turned the job down and my
wife's uncle the CBS executives said to
me this is two weeks before Cosby
premiered you're better off the shows in
a terrible timeslot it's up against
magnum p.i it's probably not gonna last
more than 13 weeks well the show came on
and lasted more than 13 weeks it was a
huge hit out of the box my wife felt
horrible at this point in time let she
denied my dream in life but it worked
out I did I had my day job at Knott's
landing got a freelance assignment on
another sitcom called Webster so I got a
writing credit that year and the
following year the baby wasn't so little
and The Cosby Show still was interested
in hiring me so I went and did the
second season of The Cosby Show so
there's an all's well that ends well
story for you
you